bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur ft france un gouvernement je
le disais enfin on re complet pourquoi
une si longue attente trois semaines
après la nomination à des ministres et
bien parce que au fond il fallait non
seulement changer les ministres mais
aussi réaffecter les attributions des
uns et des autres car le président avait
souhaité un gouvernement resserré pour
celui de jean castex n'a pas été le cas
par contre là la liste des secrétaires
d'état y beaucoup plus resserrés
puisqu'on passe de 17 à 11 ce qui a
voulu dire des réattribution des
périmètres et vous l'avait bien dit
parmi les onze nouveaux à la moitié
environ renouveler donc ça veut dire
aussi des choix en termes de compétences
pour les uns et les autres
parmi les personnalités les nouveaux
arrivants tels sont les nominations qui
vous marque peut-être celle d'un très
proche des manuels m'a conquis à clément
boon qui a toujours été de tout temps le
grand spécialiste des questions
européennes
on peut citer également la nomination
d'olivier grégoire député la république
en marche ancienne vice présidente de la
commission des finances on avait été
régulièrement avancé dans les
différentes propositions antérieures de
gouvernement ou de secrétariat d'état
elle arrive alors c'est un profil
intéressant qui vient de la droite de la
droite
autrefois madelin puis à dépasser chez
au cabinet de raffarin puis elle a été
proche de manuel valls
donc c'est une personnalité que les
médias connaissent bien parce que aide
intervient bien et puis deux modem alors
on pourrait se dire tiens c'est bizarre
la place du modem n'est pas si
importante que ça au plan du
gouvernement et des secrétariats d'état
mais la lie en a deux ils ce sont des
jeunes personnalités qui se sont fait
reconnaître dans la dernière période où
plan local lui n'arrive à la jeunesse et
l'autre à l'éducation prioritaire lune
et l'eau d'ailleurs rattaché à jean
michel blanquer à l'éducation nationale
gouvernementale et la dénaturent
justement à resserrer les rangs au sein
de la république en marche
oui c'est une façon c'est une façon
aussi de mettre en avant quand même
plutôt la compétence car seuls chic uzel
qui a été reconduite était connu du
grand public cedrico commencé à se faire
connaître à la transition numérique mais
on le sent ce sont des secrétaires
d'état qui sont à la tâche qui seront
travail qui sont réputés est attendu sur
ses dimensions d'ailleurs je crois que
ne participons pas au conseil des
ministres
c'est dire si pour le président mapon et
le premier mise castex il s'agit d'un
gouvernement au travail avec des
secrétaires d'état resserré ils seront
jugés sur la qualité de leurs actions
dans un tendre serré par la force des
choses
vous avez cité clément bonin qui est un
proche de manuel macron et qui va être
en charge donc des affaires européen
important dans le contexte actuel avec
le plan de relance en repères qui a été
acquis aux forceps et puis il ya quand
même des anciens d'edouard philippe
parmi eux on peut citer laurent petra
choses qui étaient chargés aux retraites
on sait que la rentrée elle va être
chargé là sur ce dossier là vous pensez
qu'on garde toujours la même ligne
finalement alors vous avez raison de
citer le dossier européen tout à fait
décisif le choc économique et social car
il va à la rentrée dépend beaucoup dans
sa capacité à être amorti
évidemment des plans de relance au plan
national mais aussi au plan européen et
puis derrière c'est pas très clair
est-ce que cet accord européen pour une
nouvelle période fédéralistes ou pas ou
le verra donc c'est bien que au fond les
spécialistes ne soit pas seulement des
conseillers mais aux manettes c'est le
cas de clément rhône
pour ce qui concerne leur en piètre à
celle ci vous avez raison c'était le
monsieur retraites il passe maintenant à
la santé où travaillent
c'est peut-être symboliquement le fait
que ça y est maintenant le dossier des
retraites et et est relativement baliser
ce ne sera pas la priorité du
gouvernement
et puis pour terminer marqué que la
parité semble être respectée 21 hommes à
22 femmes oublier évidemment on sait
maintenant que depuis un certain nombre
d'années
c'est une préoccupation des gouvernants
qu'au plan national la parité soit
respectée comme une sorte symboliquement
effectivement d'invitation pour les
autres secteurs de la société
d'améliorer la représentation des femmes
merci à vous stéphane rozès pour cette
analyse je rappelle que vous êtes le
président de cap enseignant à sciences
po à chasser